one question an amazing lineup of ceos
founders and experts this is marketing
for the
[Music]
now thank you so much that made me feel
[Music]
makes me giggle for some reason it's so
good to be back
happy anniversary number two gary can
you believe it two years
this show has been a lot of fun um i've
been getting a lot of emails lately from
people
um who have started marketing careers
because of this show
like literally think about that that's
amazing yeah um uh
people have gotten jobs
um
people implemented one sentence from a
cmo that's been on the show into their
career uh and their business and it's
changed things so this show has had a
big impact i'm really proud of it and
thank you for the partnership in and i'm
excited about a new episode yeah no big
shout out to our community it only makes
sense that we would actually talk about
community and the superpower today we
had 34 episodes we have over 100 000
people that tune in from all around the
world over 140 countries and we've had
290 speakers so now we got 291
alison lewis who is the chief growth
officer at kimberly clark she hails from
j j coca-cola and kraft foods before and
she leads some pretty legendary brands
including huggies kotex kleenex depend
and cottonelle
allison come on up
thanks for joining us
oh it's great to be here number 291
sounds very lucky
allison have you been
i've been great gary you know getting
back to a little traveling i think i see
you're in the office so
i i think things are getting back to a
little more normalcy although it felt
like it but it feels like there's been a
spike it felt like it but it feels like
there's a spike again and like it's just
it's just a battle but because we have
so little time let's get into this you
you know for anybody just heard like
listen to everybody who's watching when
i started vayner 13 years ago
i was like all right i'm in this world
now like what's the lay of the land then
you know just to give some roses for you
while you're on here publicly in front
of everybody like i heard your name
multiple times they're like there's this
powerhouse marketer and names i'm like
oh
i remember vividly when i met you at j j
and so you know j and j coca-cola
kimberly clark now tons of iconic brands
when you hear community the secret
superpower like when you think about
community i think you know it's really
fun and altruistic to think about when
you're a normal human being and you're
not running a big company
and it's like yeah why wouldn't you just
do what the community wants it's not
that easy back to like that old saying
from the auto industry if i gave the
customers what they want they would have
wanted a faster horse i had to invent
the car so there's a balance it's like
parenting you can't do everything the
kids want but when you think about
community in this environment 2023
looming
what uh what stands out and what do you
think big companies need to do to
harness it better and what do some of
the small entrepreneurs that are
watching here what are they doing well
and what should they continue to do well
yeah so you know it's so funny as i
reflect back on 30 years community
and sort of community marketing has
always been really important because
what matters most to people is sort of
their individual
world that they live in which usually is
tied to a community and i think when i
think about community what really
matters is
that you really understand sort of the
problem that needs to be solved
because often again to tap into a
community you have to tap into
individuals and get individual insight
and it's often very local yeah and very
small historically right but now we're
at a point where
sort of
tapping into that individual problem to
be solved recognizing that it's a
broader problem across a collective and
then gary i think the power we have
today is sort of how do you scale that
community
over
still protecting the localness of it but
that's where we get real power because
that's where you get real energy and you
get real impact
what um what's hard for big you know
again i think you can give such an
insight here what's hard
for big companies around doing things
that are more localized is it just
because they're so big it's the cliche
analogy of like it's a big it's a big
you know cruise line versus a little
motor brain and it just when you make a
decision it does take a long time for it
to turn is it is as simple as that or
um
it is the changing landscape of brand
being built in social versus television
as big of a struggle
for these organizations as i like to say
it is
you know like or is it something else
what are you seeing
i
i think it's hard because by default
you have to a be really close to
the consumer you'd be really close to
that person you're trying to influence
and and that takes hard work
um the second thing i think is just that
it has to be a segmented approach
um and so
when you think about like tapping into a
community and i'll give an example of
sort of a recent one that i'm i'm loving
and i'm over using this example but i
don't know if you're familiar with this
woman deborah james damn deborah james
from the uk who very sadly had colour
cancer and just passed away yes but you
know she became known as bowel babe um
influence and she's a great example of
garnering and building a community
that normalizes something which is the
check your poop right because she
realizes how important that is and if
you could do one more
you know if you could say one more like
it's so important but she rallied this
community behind her cause of early
detection of bowel cancer yeah raised a
ton of money you know
got got
everyone sort of thinking differently
and normalizing something that was never
talked about making a difference in the
world so
i think that's a great example of sort
of the scaling piece
but also a very segmented and unique you
know problem to be solved
um but what's hard about that is she had
to be bold right i mean she didn't talk
about something that she
people didn't normally talk about
and there's a boldness and there's an
insight that she had that was really
powerful
in the final couple of minutes
how much you know when you think about
her as a human being going through such
a devastating
journey that we all can attach to right
you know fearing for your life it just
it invokes so much in all of us
very easy
for people to latch on to
as a big company that's selling stuff
the level of citizen you know big things
are are you know have much more cynicism
in today's society government brands
platforms right look what the social
platforms are going through
what kind of conversations are you and
the top leaders of these organizations
having thinking about where like
easy for us to trust a person hard for
us to trust a big company to build that
community any
any advice you have because i've been
gearing the first half of this towards
the entrepreneurs on here but there's a
ton of fortune 500 cmos that are going
to watch us in the next 30 days what
should they be thinking about to get
that trust to even have a chance to
build community
yeah i i think again and i'll use an
example of cotex for us i mean one of
the things that we try to do is really
lean in against period stigma because
there's still a ton of period stigma out
there and you know that's something that
is a problem not only in the united
states but also in many countries around
the world so finding that problem that
the community can rally around because
they believe in that and solving that
problem is the right thing to do because
strong women and respecting women build
strong communities build strong
countries builds strength overall in
your economy so leaning into that period
stigma by associating with something
like an ngo like uh wash um united who
started menstrual hygiene day that gives
it scale
leaning in against period stigma and
then localizing it through the work that
you do and leveraging digital and social
and all those tools to really make it
feel very local so like in south africa
you know creating an uh
rap song around period stigma and what
people feel by garnering you know that
insight from the local market of what
those humans in south africa really feel
about quick period stigma so the advice
is really find something that everyone
can rally around so you know balba found
something that everyone could rally
around and made a difference period
stigma is something that everyone can
rally around because they want women to
progress
most human beings don't want stigma
associated with periods because they're
very important in in human life um and
so that is my advice to everyone find
something that everyone can rally around
then you'll get the scale
in addition to the ability to localize
well i love the format for the speed but
i get sad because i want to talk for
another hour but allison thank you so
much continued success have a great rest
of the summer
awesome great being with you guys lucky
291 take care 291
thank you alison
gary we're excited to bring up patricia
corsi next from
buyer or as we say in the united states
bear
patricia you you hold a lot of titles
chief marketing digital and information
officer
and you're quite the globetrotter as
well and a bit of a renegade um right
now patricia is on a mission to rev up
creativity um and build the community in
her entire category and she's even
partnering with competitors to do it
welcome patricia
thank you very much uh for the
invitation gary i was i was telling
andrea every time that we meet we are
not in the us and now i know
yeah in video
well listen i'm uh
i'm a big fan of your renegade dna i'm
really happy you're here i you know i'm
such an outsider to add land as an
entrepreneur and just my natural
kind of points of view of like
opportunities usually sit in places
people don't see so
when i'm able to find somebody who holds
these big jobs that actually sees
consumer first i'm always attached to
them and and i root for you heavy and
it's so nice to be with you
thank you the pleasure is mutual thank
you very much and and let's get to it
because i love what you're discussing
with alison and and really want to share
well let's yeah let's build on it
obviously we just you know talked on
that from something she said or a
different angle or a build on right off
the bat what what what do you want to
build on top of what you just heard
let's start with that
um look i think the first thing and i
think you are you are the the master of
doing this i think there is no size one
no one size fits all and i think really
having this ability to really in
listening with intent and being
interested in being engaged i think
allows us to define some of the norms so
talking about some of the points on
having the localization
we started with a campaign for example
called
vagina academy that it was really to
help women to get educated about their
intimate parts because this is really
taking a a burden in women and we
started in brazil my my home country and
we educated a
big bunch of women all through this
community of influencers that represent
the people that we were serving and we
thought this is going to be you know a
brazilian thing and it was super
successful we uncensored the word vagina
on tick tock in brazil and we felt like
we are really doing something for the
society um to our surprise now we have
at the university of down there in
australia doing it with their local spin
on it and then we have uk doing it with
their local spin on it and italy italy
and censoring it on meta so
i think great ideas they they fly and
you just need to have that freedom
within a framer not trying to
micromanage especially you were talking
about us being in big corporations
multi-billion corporations and sometimes
from the ivory tower you're trying to
micromanage people that are really
listening to to the phone consumer
yeah a bit like you i come from an
interpreter family and in my father's
restaurant it's all about understanding
the person that you're serving in that
moment
get everything right
so that is one thing that i wanted to
share based on that discussion the other
is a different one that i think is the
role that big corporations
have to step up to the plate and on this
mission really to help people to take
better care of their health i'm
200 percent committed and i think about
the younger people that think they're
invincible they're not taking care of
their health and by health i mean mental
health as well this has to be a taboo
that gets out
mental health physical health emotional
health we are partnering with the
communities of gamers how you know i
have a 14 year old son
lorenzo is going to watch this lorenzo
and
we partner with gaming you know free fly
because how do we teach people young
generation that they need to defend
their immune system to be protected
what is a better way than they know in
the video game that they have to defend
themselves yes
so we work with the community of players
and the response is amazing we had
gamers that kept talking about our
brands and what we were doing much after
the sponsorship stop so
these are the small things that
sometimes we get hooked to say oh no but
this you know it doesn't fit this mode
it doesn't fit this mode especially in
big
corporations but i i am a big proponent
of big ideas and i know you're super fun
because you're all about big ideas that
we make an impact right so i i spoke
already too much go for it no you're
amazing that's why i stay quiet when i
hear amazing things let's um
let's talk about let's go very nerdy
this is most of this has been for
everybody by the way i'm seeing all of
you on facebook on uh on linkedin on
youtube i see your comments you see my
eye looking at it christian bl i see
that you want a job it's vaynerx.com you
can fill it out there um but
but this one i'm gonna go very inside
baseball because marketing for now is
watched by so many marketers around the
world i'm gonna go very nerdy b2b
with what is needed by let me help my
competitors for a minute
the big agencies
the agencies the world
they're getting caught right now because
you know if you look at the netflix
earnings yesterday like they've got dave
i mean anybody who's watching this that
thinks network television is around let
alone commercials on network television
shows in five to ten years is out of
their mind absolutely everything that i
watch from you from afar and then
listening to your first five minutes
here what should the partners that are
helping fortune 500 companies be doing
to be prepared to be able to actually
help them
because the concept of hiring very
expensive people to just sit in a room
and come up with an idea for a
television commercial you've you know i
know that you and all your competitors
are still spending that way but it's
just a matter of time at this point what
should they be thinking about let's help
some agency owners have a chance to be
successful in the future what what
should they be thinking about the first
thing i think is you have this mindset
that you and i have that is i want my
competitors to be giants in terms
because i want to be better than giants
i don't want to compete with people that
are mediocre so i want my competitors to
to push me to take to the next level
it's it's not fun to compete with people
that you don't admire respect and you
think that you know i like that a lot
um so i've as andrea was saying i
invited one of my my competitors to a
panel at khans to talk about how do we
transform the industry because this is
the point on community and collaboration
yeah and i think the big
the big agencies and i i see at least in
the ones that partner with us that this
mindset has disappeared because it's
part of our mentality now they have a
group where they all have dinner
together and they meet together because
that we have one goal and when they come
to me and said no but i have this idea
and the other one doesn't like i said
you go back and you solve it
and for because it's all for the benefit
of the people that we serve and i think
this mentality to i compete with the
other i think it's also very small
it's not only small i'm sorry to
interrupt
it's
it's it's not understanding that the
world is abundant
i want to win in everything i'm very
competitive look
i want to win every time
but
when people get nasty with each other
just because they compete
you know your father
restaurant
i grew up in my father's liquor stores
we have a connection of course they
wanted somebody to come into their store
and restaurant versus the guy or girl
across the street it was very local
competition
but still but still at the end of the
day
there's a lot of liquor stores there's a
lot of restaurants there's enough for
everyone to eat you should be
competitive and want to win that's nice
but not become nasty
you know with agencies all the
interagency politics just to get a
little more scope it makes it terrible
for you the client because you're
spending all your time managing people's
feelings instead of doing great work
look i couldn't be more with you and we
were just a couple of weeks back in the
french riviera fighting for for this
industry that we love so much
and i think it's a very easy job to
trash others and to going back to our
background where we learn from the best
i think is the way that you get people
to keep coming to your business is by
doing better things it's to search for
greatness not by threshing and looking
oh look how they're doing bad so
this is also a mindset and a change
management process that you have to do
that whenever someone comes and said
look how bad they did and i said i'm
looking for what they did right and i'm
looking for what's the learning that i'm
going to get from that because i'm sure
they didn't they're smart people and
they didn't went from an intention that
says okay let's do crappy stuff
there is no briefing that starts with
that there is something there not to
mention i'm sorry to interrupt you when
people are trying to make themselves
look better by [ __ ] on someone else
they suck that's the whole problem with
everyone like everyone right now
everyone thinks by saying that person
sucks or you're the worst or i'm
canceling you or you [ __ ] suck
miraculously that makes them look better
what a joke you want to look better
build other people up
this is it and and and by the way
i tell you because i know you shared
this feeling with me when you do that
building yourself that inspire the
people to build themselves it gives you
when you see people
learning from your mistakes and getting
better and ascending
you have a sense of accomplishment that
is
so
so important and so fulfilling that is
so different that this this small thing
so in a nutshell what we need to do is
to stop
you know pushing the bar lower so we can
look our jump can look higher so the
first thing with our agency second be
super clear you know
do some you know do some debate do some
friction because fire great fire will
come and it's the is the same process of
the diamond put pressure on it you have
a diamond you don't put pressure on it
you don't come so i think having those
concussions and not going around the the
political bit of of managing like you
say those egos i think is one thing that
really works for us and and and this is
something that
you know i stay very close to you and i
will keep pushing it
and i'm proud of you we're out of time i
go so fast i know it goes so fast i'm
cheering for you always here for you
we'll talk soon bye
bye
that one full of heart oh my goodness
there was a lot there right so much
there oh i was writing everything down
i'm gonna i'm gonna read it like reading
i'm like reading all the comments like
you know it's just um
you know i gotta go and i know you gotta
keep the show going but i just
tearing other people down
as a proxy to make yourself seem better
than thou whether in business setting or
in social media for like it's just like
where is the civility and the compassion
and the kindness and we're just so into
shaming and cancelling and judging and
politicking against and i'm not even
talking politics i'm talking in the
business world and in politics
it's just time for more good it's just
time to be nice it's just time to care
if somebody's mean to you feel
compassion for them they're in a bad
spot be the bigger person be the bigger
person we've completely lost the ability
to be the bigger person in the face of
[ __ ]
yeah i mean the humanity that just came
out in that conversation is you know
it's real and you know the fact that you
you are out there meeting with a bunch
of competitors and
both you guys were right i want i want
my competitors to do well i don't want
them to go out of business and not like
do i want to beat them every time yes
but do i want them to go out of business
or be harmed or do i think they're jerks
of course not i want them to live a
happy life it's like sports like you
know you're playing sports you want to
win but you don't want somebody to get
injured or or like hurt or like i just
don't understand like i'm the most
competitive
hey you know
without a doubt but but you have more
humanity at the same time yeah you and
you can balance those things you can and
everybody watching aspire to it's nice
it's just [ __ ] nice all right go do
your thing great thank you gary
and welcome ryan harwood
are you there are you there i am here
hello andrea how's it going it's so good
we are so lucky we finally got vinay
shahan
shahadi to join us can you believe it we
got him we got him
vinay is the vice president of lexis
marketing um and he is an industry icon
he's worked at a whole slew of different
uh auto brands including toyota
volkswagen and nissan
but not only in marketing he's worked in
manufacturing and engineering and sales
and product management
so there's nothing that you haven't done
so i'm really fired up to hear this
conversation
over to you guys
awesome hey vinay how's it going
hey ryan how are you man
i'm good i'm good thanks for joining us
you know just coming off that last
conversation that gary is having just
want to say one comment on that to the
audience because it's funny the second
that i came into gary's world and his
ecosystem
um the first thing he said to me was
we're we're not going to tear other
buildings down we're going to try to
build the biggest building and i thought
that was something that really really
resonated with me so i just wanted to
throw that out there to the audience and
kind of close that loop on that
conversation they were having because
that quote always resonated with me but
shifting here for a second vinay kyo
tell the audience a little bit more
about about you in a nutshell and how
and when did you get started at lexus
yeah thanks for that and first of all
thanks for having me this has just been
so inspiring to hear from some of the
other leaders so far uh it's it's a
great question um i'll rewind the clock
a little bit and and give you a little
bit of context so i was born and raised
near detroit
uh so car culture as you would imagine
is was definitely part of my upbringing
and in fact it was my dad you know he
was a mechanical engineer at ford motor
company his entire career
and and i guess i was inspired by him um
you know between my dad and the ford
mustang and the porsche 911
i was a car guy at a very early age and
i'll never forget ryan i think it was
1990 one of my dad's colleagues brought
his wife's lexus ls400 over to our house
that was lexus's first ever product they
were launched in 1989.
and like i did with all of our family
friends i grabbed the keys i went looked
at the car and i just couldn't believe
what a fantastic car it was
and i ended up getting an engineering
degree after that and six years after
first experiencing that lexus one of my
first jobs in the industry was to
benchmark the ls400 bought one drove it
all over the place tested everything
tore it down
and it was all about
seeing how did they do it how did they
disrupt the industry back then and i've
held the brand in highest steam ever
since then
fast forward uh got a lot of technical
roles developed an affinity for the
commercial side of the business ended up
going back to school got my mba joined
nissan worked all across the value chain
i ended up in marketing got poached to
go be the cmo at vw i ended up hitting a
little bit of a rough spot during their
dieselgate crisis but that was a
tremendous learning opportunity and it
gave me the license to have
conversations with other leaders one of
them was jack hollis who was a cmo of
toyota at the time
and after hitting it off with him and
talking about going through a crisis
which toyota had done before through
their unintended acceleration
he gave me the opportunity to join
toyota in 17
initially running marketing operations
and then eventually moving over the
lexus side a year and a half ago and now
it's just been great you know we're
trying to reposition the brand towards
electrification towards performance and
starting to build bridges with you know
young affluent guests and consumers
while not alienating our our loyal base
that have gotten us here so far
i love it i love it i recently saw the
lexus lc and it is a gorgeous vehicle
really really yeah you know the lc is is
a fantastic product um and you know
there's there's an opportunity there
that you know historically speaking
uh lexus has been known for
quality durability and reliability you
know and even though we've had
performance vehicles in the lineup like
the lc 500 like the is 500 the rcf
we don't always get a lot of credibility
for that or credit for developing those
performance vehicles so that's been one
of my missions
is to make sure that those halo vehicles
create more excitement around the brand
and we have a lot of specific
initiatives that are aimed towards the
community to fire them up as a base
which help us get the word out on on
that you know those important vehicles
in the lineup
so we're in a post-ish pandemic world
here you know it's a very interesting
time what are you seeing in terms of
changes in consumer behavior and how
that impacts your approach to community
building for the lexus brand
yeah you know the communities everything
to us um you know as we've heard from
the other speakers you know at the core
of our community are
our lexus loyalists
many of whom own lexus vehicles some of
whom don't you know they're young people
who love the brand yeah they can't
afford to buy a car yet
but we want to foster that and fan that
flame
but what we found is
these people at the core
are so impactful in driving word of
mouth
uh you know affinity for the brand and
also driving demand these days
you know they're the center of their
circles they provide advice to their
families and friends
so we obviously want to take care of
them and we want to really get them
excited about the brand
um but you know you look around today
i don't think there's any industry that
wouldn't say that there's crazy [ __ ]
happening all around us you know demand
is sky high right now for our products
yeah but it's also way higher than the
capacity of what we can actually build
so there's you know some good and bad
associated with that
um you know one one thing that we've
seen is
there's a very strong demand
from our guests our consumers our core
community to get out there and
experience things they're tired of
staying home
they're out and about doing things and
and very fortunate to be able to kind of
take that inspiration and do things
differently
i think one one good example uh we'll go
in the performance category since you
brought up the lc 500.
you know we do this thing called the
lexus performance driving school
that's where we take
consumers and we teach them how to race
a car whether it's drifting whether it's
on an autocross track um you know we've
got scott pruitt townsend bell two of
our
uh race car drivers that help teach
these classes
and you know we get these rave reviews
things sold out every single time
but one of the things that we felt would
be important was to reward some of these
members of our community with something
special to commemorate the experience so
we interrogated the data from the car to
get
speed and
g-force and all sorts of cool metrics
and we created a unique nft for each of
the participants
that commemorates how they performed on
the track
but combined it with really cool uh
images of the track dynamic footage of
taking an aggressive turn and this is
something that just you know we don't
have to do this we don't charge any
money for that but this is about
rewarding the community and we see them
become even stronger advocates of the
lexus brand which is obviously what
we're trying to do
yeah that's awesome well i could talk to
you for so much longer this goes so
quick it's absurd i have like five more
questions i want to go but i am going to
do my patented speed round with you
because i want everyone to get to know
vinay so i'm going four questions quick
all right vanilla chocolate
oh definitely chocolate no question
50s or 60s music
man i'm a big rolling stones fan and a
doors fan so i got to say 60s on that
okay adam sandler or will ferrell movies
oh one word elf will ferrell all day
long
and last italian or mediterranean food
well i grew up in dearborn michigan
which is really really big on
mediterranean food so i gotta go
mediterranean there we go renee thank
you so much for joining us we really
appreciate the time and uh
we'll see you soon sounds great thanks
for the time great to see you both
thanks renee
all right ryan next up we've got billy
lagar who's joining us senior vice
president of brand management for the
wines and spirits division of
constellation brands
billy leads a yummy portfolio i'm gonna
let him list off the the long list it's
making me thirsty that's for sure uh he
also has a passion for building winning
cultures and brands driving innovation
and transforming organizations welcome
billy
thank you for having me hey how are you
great yourself
good good good to see you thanks for
joining us today happy to be here
all right let's jump right in because
these do go way too fast so you know we
obviously have gotten to know each other
over the last year so i know you spent
about 15 years at hasbro toy and games
company what's the biggest surprise as
you've entered the wine and spirit space
at constellation yeah i know it's a
great one you know i think you know what
they're having the two companies have in
common they're both passion oriented
people love the brands people want to
engage in the brands i think the
difference particularly in the wine
category is you have so much engagement
and passion over this
but it's the hardest category to shop
right you go in there and you look at
the wine aisle and i love wine and i
work here now and i look at half of
these things and i don't know what they
are right and even you know being called
the cabernet sauvignon that doesn't mean
the same thing everywhere so you know to
me the big difference is navigation of
this category it's just hard and and
it's it's you know puts it a lot of
effort on us to try to simplify and
hopefully have people choose our brands
but really help people understand the
category
absolutely it makes a lot of sense uh i
i love wine and i still
have difficulty navigating the category
a lot because like you said there's just
a lot of nuance to it
um so you joined at a very interesting
time right there were some hints that
were transitioning back into this
post-pandemic world i'm i'm curious what
are you seeing in terms of changes in
consumer behavior and and how has that
impacted your approach to
community building for all the various
wine brands
yeah that's a great one i mean i think
some of the changes you know the past
few years and it's between the pandemic
and just a very you know divisive
political environment you know i think
so some of the big trends we're seeing
one is
folks are really doubling down and
having great experiences right it really
has become far more than we've ever seen
a quality over quantity type of uh type
of uh you know environment right so
really showing folks why this is the
best choice to give you that best
experience i think the other thing is as
a brand
you know and i think some of this is due
to just the lack of faith in you know
other institutions brands are expected
to take stands on issues they weren't
before right i mean you know everybody
talks about the example with disney and
don't say gay right here's a brand that
never had to get involved but now if i
love disney you need to show that you
accept me and my partner and so i need
to see your statement right and i think
we're seeing the role that brands need
to take whether it's you know roe versus
wade or whatever's happening brands now
need to stand for something that
you know really dives into their
consumers lives and show that their
values are shared in a way that that has
never really been the case before
yeah that's that's really great point
and it's challenging for brands to do
that particularly because you know you
might have multiple different views at
the tippy top of company so that's a
really interesting point
and what about internal like how are you
personally modeling or creating the
community you're trying to create with
your staff
yeah and again i think as you know the
workplace as you know just the work
model has blown up right people don't or
many people don't go into the office you
have people in three or four days a week
people who have never been in the office
you know i started here
where there wasn't an office open yet
and i think that you know the key things
for me is i i think it's things that we
need to be good leaders and even good
brain builders which is first is empathy
and understanding and if you think about
we're talking to people now and you know
you know you could be in your home and
there's your child running around that's
a different kind of empathy and
connection that we need to understand
and respect and you know have
flexibility with that i think you know
it really forces us to go on those kind
of emotional side of the the skill block
and make sure we understand that the
situation that folks and the other thing
though is i think as leaders which i
think is a positive is
you know because we if you think about
we've stripped out the commonality of
everyone goes into work goes in the same
meetings does the same things it really
forces us to think about what's the
results and what's the value you're
adding and really how do we make sure
that each person succeeds
given the choice that
they're making and how they're going to
work so i think you know if you if you
step back there's actually a lot of
positive because it helps people focus
on balancing life which is more
important than work right um but also
how do we succeed and work in a way that
um helps us leverage the you know the
circumstances we're all in so i think
that's been a good positive test for uh
for a lot of us
yeah i i've really enjoyed that aspect
of you know meeting with our staff and
even clients just in the background when
you get to see a little bit of insight
into their lives and you get to know
them a little bit better than just kind
of the boardroom so i've actually
enjoyed that part of the pandemic
um and what are you guys doing on
platforms today that that taps into
culture that perhaps you didn't do in
the past
yeah i actually think there's a lot
there i think it's a combination of two
things one is there's so much realities
you know working work working with you
guys
there's so much in terms of data in
understanding the consumer and i think
the big change is you know marketing
used to be you come up with this one
monolithic positioning this one
monolithic statement this one composite
of a consumer that doesn't actually
exist right like there's not right
you're kind of aggregating to get to
this one person and i think you know
what's changed now about how we think
about consumers is who are the
individuals that we're talking to what
do they have in common how can we find
them and how can we talk them and while
sometimes you need kind of a you know a
bigger point of view right you can't
have 100 different packages but we can
talk to groups of consumers differently
and i think that's the big thing when
you think about platforms is it gives us
the ability to say you know we have a
brand like kim crawford right anyone who
loves it's my favorite one that we have
savion blanc it's amazing but what was
interesting is when you look at the
groups that like it you have a suburban
mom with three kids and an urban gay man
right those are really different groups
we can't talk to them the same way
even though they may love the product
and maybe even love it for the same way
and i think where the platforms come in
as we say it gives us the chance to how
do we build relationships
with very different groups with
messaging that stays core to who the
brand is but also respects the fact that
we're talking to different people so
that to me has been the biggest shift
because it really lets us
really build relationships and not
trying to find this this kind of
mythical composite of a you know
consumer person that doesn't exist
anyway
yeah the days of creating one vanilla
message to to reach and resonate with
everybody are long gone so that makes a
lot of sense
and
you know what are things that maybe you
stopped doing as you try to engage more
with audiences that matter to the
constellation brands
these relate to what i just said you
know it's really kind of stopping that
idea that one size fits all you know and
what's interesting for us is you know
wine we're not a brand that goes for
ubiquity right like our yeah we make
corona amazing beer everyone knows what
corona is right not everyone drinks wine
and not everyone knows what naomi is so
we're going after you know a hostile
penetration from one to two percent to
get it to four or five that's a
different challenge than if you are
corona right who's already got the
ubiquity and you're trying to drive
drive more that way so for us it's
really been how do we really take deep
points of view right because if we're
only trying to get to five percent of
the population then we don't have to
worry about a lot of the population we
can say for those of you that love this
brand
we can really lean into a deeper more
relevant position tidy your you know tie
our values to yours and communicate
in a way that you can't really do if
you're kind of a is a more mass brand so
that to me has been the biggest change
is is let's you know it's not so much of
a stop as much of a start and really
start focusing on who are we what do we
really stand for and how can we
courageously lean into that through
dialogue with our you know with our most
passionate consumers
makes a lot of sense
and last question here you know what's
one new thing you've learned since
you've joined constellation
yeah no that's a great one and um you
know i think it's not so much a new
thing that you learn but something that
you just more realize is you know being
at hasbro for 15 years and i have
nothing but love for hasbro but when
you're there for 15 years you know the
people you know the systems you almost
have too much history for your own good
and i think what's been nice coming here
is
i don't know this ninja this is a new
industry for me and it really really
forces you to double down on humility
and listening to your team and
vulnerability because you know you're
coming in it's you know this cool big
job and you're like i don't know a word
you just said can you use baby talk to
explain it and so you know for me that's
kind of the learning but more saying you
know hopefully over time i'll i will
know more and understand more and you
know for me the question is how do you
keep that kind of curiosity and
open-mindedness once you start getting
the experience right because you'll want
your experience to trump the openness
that you have to just learn and listen
and so that i think has been the you
know the biggest learning one of the
funnest parts about about joining here
yeah you didn't come in jaded from the
liquor industry the ways things were
done in the past you're seeing it with
fresh eyes i love that i had a similar
experience when i went from finance to
media back in 2010 i didn't know the
first clue about media and i was jumping
head first in as a media company and i
just asked a billion questions in order
to understand you have to have no shame
about asking a million questions and not
feel insecure about it frankly yeah and
it really helps you just you realize
like just we have just such great people
here and just seeing how folks respond
to things that you're almost i would say
nervous about but you feel like you
should know and you know it's just you
have folks who are just so talented and
awesome and kind and just the patients
that take it really the patience it
takes to explain it sometimes you know
it really just makes you feel part of
the culture so it's just been a really
it's made that kind of onboarding to a
new company really really excellent
all right here we go speed round for
billy everyone get to know billy a
little bit here all right salty or sweet
definitely sweet
80s or 90s music there is no decade like
the 80s when it comes to music i agree
with you let's hear it for the boys
sly stallone or schwarzenegger movies
you know it's a tough one but i've got
to go with uh sly i better rule out
arnold because of his politics so
i'm gonna go with uh with fly
beacher mountains you know beach because
my dog would be happiest there
morning person or night person uh
definitely a morning person
last one friends are seinfeld i am going
to trump that and go to fitch creek
oh shit's creek i haven't heard that
before there we go good one thank you
very much for joining us billy i
appreciate your time awesome thank you
great talking 80s 80s 80s thank you
billy
thank you
you're awesome ryan thank you so much
we're going to welcome chris anthony up
from vayner's gallery media group
chris just joined us and i love that you
raise your hand right away and jump on
into marketing for the now welcome chris
thanks andrew so excited i and i'm
particularly excited about this
conversation uh we're going to be
bringing craig up who's the cmo of
american eagle outfitters and he joined
in 2020 and prior that he'd worked for
so many iconic brands uh including gap
and abercrombie and fitch and calvin
klein and he's now built gen z's number
one retailer and he's been leaning into
a lot around youth culture including the
metaverse innovation influencer
partnerships and comm and community
impact
craig
so fired up thanks for joining us hey
thanks for having me just a good excuse
to stay inside during the heat of new
york city right chris so hot i know i
feel like it's every day gets hotter and
hotter so agree i'll do this inside and
enjoy the air conditioning
um so excited to see you craig um lots
of good stuff to talk about jump right
in um
you know this is all about community and
i think like my first question i feel
like you know web 3
you know it's so synonymous with that
word right um and i think that so many
brands are still in that phase of
learning and sort of exploring you guys
i feel like have jumped right in and
been really bullish and did some
interesting stuff which is really
exciting talk about that a little bit
and talk about what you're excited about
the future in that space too for the
brand
yeah chris we're the number one retailer
for gen z and in that humble position
you have to stand for youth culture and
very clearly all things metaverse is
something that our core customer is
excited about so partnering with vayner
we've been very early and very bullish
on opportunities in the so-called
metaverse and so we're one of the first
retailers to drop at nft
we've had some amazing success with our
snap partners in virtual augmented
reality pop-up stores we're actually
making money making lots of money which
is exciting and then we launched a
roblox experience back in march we've
had 25 million unique visitors to date
14 million of those actually tried on ae
close for their avatar
and many of them have obviously gone to
the physical space to buy the product as
well so we're really excited about
what's coming down the line
we have a very
packed back half schedule in the
metaverse my team will kill me if i tell
everything that we're doing um but it
will include more um in-store
experiences so the bridging the physical
in in digital in store is something that
we're particularly excited about as well
i love that um when you just touched on
in-store um
in the same vein of community you know i
think in layman's terms a lot of us
think about local right and local means
community community and local talk about
how that is sort of like how you sort of
harness sort of the locality and what
local means to the brand
it's but it's funny chris because we
actually have 900 stores we're the
second largest physical store fleet in
specialty retail
and that can make us feel honestly too
big and a bit overwhelming
but when you think about it those are
900 individual stores that are serving
individual communities and we've leaned
deeply into all things influencers
and so whether it's addison ray or the
kids from outer banks we work with them
but the light bulb went off and we
thought wait we have 35 000 store
associates vast majority of them are gen
z
vast majority are diverse and provide
different and unique voices for their
generation why don't we activate these
people as well so we've
started a new influencer program called
my ae
and these store associates have in-store
events
have local community impact
and have become literally the number one
engage with content on our social
platforms
so wildly successful
and talk about community these kids live
eat and breathe our brand and they know
our communities better than anyone
love that so so so smart um you said
something about like this generation um
which
is such an incredible customer for you
guys and always has been and i think
this generation even more so cares about
the future and sort of being on the
right side of history there's obviously
a lot going on in the world um and kind
of it's a more complicated world growing
up today um and standing up for purpose
is something that i think you guys are
doing such an incredible job how do you
sort of balance sort of all of the
causes and why is it so important to you
guys as a brand to sort of rally around
you know these important causes to the
communities that are you know
underserved that are um american eagle
customers or future customers even so
appreciate the question chris and it's a
fact a total fact that american eagle
and our sister brand arie have been
ahead of the curve on gen z values for
quite some time so
when you see places like victoria's
secret
um or you see places like abercrombie
start
pretending to be more inclusive our two
brands have been there for you know
almost over a decade
and i can tell you to your point that
gen z votes
with their values
and we're really pleased that we have a
panel of 2000 ae customers aged 15 to 25
that we can ask any question on any day
at any time and we do
that could be advertising related but it
certainly is values related as well
and um that feedback gives us an
opportunity to to focus our energy
behind the core causes for gen z
and in this pandemic
they've spoken very loudly mental health
the biggest challenge out there
continuing to make progress in terms of
more planet positive goods we've
certainly made progress on that social
justice uh an important opportunity as
well so um
it's um it's so um important to listen
to the customer and so important to hear
from gen z directly yeah so important
and the love the work you guys are doing
which is pretty incredible
um you touched on this a little bit
about um tick tock and some of the
platforms um and some of the work you
guys have done really early on in the
platform and sort of finding like the
right talent and building really great
relationships um how do you think about
you know your own tick tock presence
versus what you guys are doing in the
paid space um and how you're sort of
harnessing the insights and like that
community and using that as a whole new
marketing channel because of just the
power of what tick tock has become
it's funny chris because i actually have
had to unlearn everything that i did
learn as a head of marketing um you know
as as
you kindly mentioned in the intro um you
know i kind of grew up with big
lifestyle brands like calvin like
abercrombie which were very high touch
high command high control well that
ain't cool anymore
so that's especially true in tick tock
and what we have found that anytime we
try to put out brand content on tick
tock quite honestly
anytime we do our homework and we find
the right influencers to accelerate our
messaging it kills it um
continue to do that um and i love the
fact that our team is developing tops
down bottoms up strategy on that
platform and so again we work with some
of the biggest names out there but just
as important are these micro influencer
kids that are just becoming to to be
more and more
popular our back to school campaign
launches next week it's the super bowl
for us
this season it's all about music and
genes and this season it's about finding
new voices on platforms like tick tock i
love that you just brought up a good
point about back to school holiday which
are obviously you know major moments and
you know define sort of the success for
the rest of the category with just sort
of the the constant culture shifts and
tick-tock and sort of the virality of
trends that are constantly happening how
has that sort of changed how you plan in
a very structured retail calendar for
retail and how
is the the planning shorter what has
that changed in terms of getting ready
for this big season that you guys are
all you know about to embark on
i think this year i mean listen 2020
never seen it before 2021 never seen it
before and here we go again in 2022 i've
never seen this in my long retail career
so basically chris we've had to blow up
the plan and
we've had to react uh
way closer in than one might have before
um the cool thing though is that you
know we feel like we're an entertainment
company just as much as an apparel
company we're putting out more than 400
pieces of content each week um and our
ability to turn and pivot and move and
groove during some of these changes to
me is amazing um and we'll do that this
season you know we have to talk about
value in a way that perhaps we didn't
anticipate we're gonna have to talk
about sustainability and enduring
quality um a little bit louder than we
than we probably have had before and yet
gen z is living their best life this
summer i mean they're out and having a
great time and so this is not a downer
at all this this is going to be a very
optimistic approach to this season as
well um and we're we're pretty
optimistic that back to school um
american eagle will be a strong winner
and a strong performer during this
season yeah i mean it sounds like an
incredible work you guys put into some
exciting ideas so i'm sure it will be um
you mentioned a few um brands that you
feel like
were behind in some of the curve when it
came to inclusivity things like that
what are some brands
maybe not even in the category of retail
that you feel like you admire of what
they're doing right now
wow i mean that that is a a great
question i want to get stay out of the
apparel kayaker because i don't want to
give any of those friends um you know
heads up that we're watching we're we're
watching you um
you know i i think the previous speaker
um from consolation brought up a really
good point i think that
all of us are navigating a new normal
where brands are asked to um get
involved in social commentary of the day
and and what i really appreciate is when
a brand is authentic and doing that not
performative not checking a box and so i
think any brand that comes into a
conversation feeling authentic authentic
feeling transparent
and being a little bit vulnerable is
winning with the customer out there um
obviously we just went through you know
supreme court um big ruling um
and you know i was i was really pleased
with so many marketers so many brands
out there that hit the right tone in
this challenging moment
so great um another question kind of
shifting gears a little bit like we
talked a lot about sort of how you're
engaging the consumers what does sort of
community mean to you in your marketing
or in your team like how do you sort of
foster that environment um it sounds
like you guys are doing incredible work
externally what does that look like
internally even outside of sort of like
the local influencer store team like
within your own team
the cool thing is i work with the best
damn team in retail marketing bar none
um but it's weird um you know as you
mentioned at the top i joined in july of
2020 height of the pandemic right on
board through a screen um and you know i
ain't good at everything but i do think
i'm good at building relationship with
people especially in the real world um
but we've all gotten used to this hybrid
um um work um and i think this has
allowed people to
merge personal and professional like
never before
and when i talk to our associates they
do want to be in office every every few
days and they do want to to connect and
i'm in a business where you want to look
touch and feel and be inspired by
product having said that i've got a lot
of working moms i've got baseball coach
dads i've got you know people with other
varied interests and the way that we're
fostering the community is
we're not going to command the control
from the top if you if you are
are you giving it you're bringing it and
you and you're supporting our brand and
our business i don't really care where
you do it from so i think that that's
fostered a new way of community for our
internal team
awesome um we're almost out of time one
last question a fun one um back to
school season upon us what's what are
the must have that we need to get from
the brand um as we're doing shopping for
back to school season
listen we're the number one selling
genes for women of all ages and we have
about 25 market share for gen z in both
gender so it's jeans jeans and jeans for
her you've probably seen it out and
about it's baggy and wide leg cuddling
at the bottom that's hot um for our guy
he's also kim becoming a little bit more
confident and he's kind of going og
straight so that is fun um we're kind of
at the tail end of 90s from a top's
perspective so y2k is coming up um and
chris as i just mentioned
in all the doom and gloom that all of us
are experiencing somehow gen z is
leaning toward towards the glass half
full
bright optimistic color um is something
that we're seeing in the marketplace for
back to school as well yeah i love that
yeah i feel like if we can harness that
positivity in that generation and all
take it in maybe the world will be a
better place um every single day
i'm with you fingers crossed
yeah awesome um
this was super great um and congrats on
all the amazing work and rooting for you
for the back for holiday and back to
school sounds like a ton of amazing
stuff ahead
appreciate it chris and hey
congratulations that was your first
vayner
vayner convo here i hope we did it i
hope you did okay
he did it and you you did a great job
too craig thanks for all those tips for
i wrote them all down i'm i'm heading
i'm
i'm heading right back to school all the
way
exactly thanks to you both
thank you thanks craig thanks andrew
next we're going to welcome up
vaynermedia's chief diversity officer
vanessa vining
hi how are you i am so good i'm so glad
that you could join us you're in i
believe you're in london are you not
still i am but i have the opportunity
couldn't miss it i didn't care where i
was on the globe you are the best you
are the best yeah the london office is
growing by leaps and bounds and uh very
exciting that you could join the
festivities is it still like painfully
hot there
no the temperature is much more
manageable excellent okay that's what we
want to hear well we're going to have a
hot conversation today because we've got
sam saperstein joining us from jpmorgan
chase and she does some pretty um
unbelievable things she runs something
called
the
um
women on the move and i i actually met
sam in davos where she was talking quite
a bit about the program um she's going
to fill you in on all the details but
it's a big bold mission and it's making
a huge difference out in the world so so
excited to have you both join in
conversation welcome sam
thank you it's great to see you both
thank you
first i want to say it's such a pleasure
to meet you sam and i personally
appreciate all that you're doing to
support and empower women in your work
so thank you for being with us today um
in your role as the head of a women on
the move at chase how do you view
commute the community as a super power
and what does that mean to you
i think community is everything we
probably relearned this lesson in kovid
when we couldn't see people and be with
them it really took away from our
day-to-day our mental health and
everything so for us as a very broad
community of women it's really the
source of what drives us what gives us
our strength and when i really think
about what is at the heart of community
to me it's these bonds that sometimes
you have with people you don't even know
personally and i'll give you an example
of when this really came to light for me
so we launched women on the move four
years ago it was the first time we had a
dedicated group for women globally where
we were going to look at things for
women inside and outside of the firm and
so we put out a memo across the whole
firm emailed everyone globally and i
can't tell you the number of emails i
got from people all over the world
people i did not even know
saying we're so excited this is such a
source of pride and then it would always
end with how can i help you
and i got this from a lot of women but
also a lot of men and when those folks
all came out to sort of wish me well and
join the cause i knew we were really
onto something so to me community is
that influence and almost that invisible
hand that's sometimes out there when you
don't even know it and i think for me
personally too if i thought about my own
personal communities
i have a very broad community now of
women on the move volunteers we have
tens of thousands of women around the
company that have signed up just to be a
member of this but then closer to home i
obviously have more personal communities
communities of smaller groups maybe
their co-workers that i spend time with
or professional organizations so i think
everyone can have different levels of
community and you'll flex depending on
when you need to tap that community for
different things
yes i tell you i am a big fan of
everything that you do at chase i mean
you have all my money i am a customer
and have been for a long time
it just makes me feel more confident
that my money and my commitment is in
the right place when i hear about
programs like what you and what you're
doing at chase for women um there's and
i agree with you there's been a massive
movement to support women
um different organizations have stepped
up like chief for example having over 10
000 women in leadership and all the
things that they do
the next question i have for you is you
know from a professional standpoint how
do you see women show up for each other
in this time yeah
so you know sometimes i still get the
question are women really helping each
other or are women still backstabbing
each other and i find that really to be
a very disappointing question i don't
personally see that and i haven't
experienced that my experience has been
women have been fantastic for me i've
had great women bosses i was hired by
two fantastic women into jpmorgan chase
and so i've had the benefit of really
learning from terrific leaders but
broader than that i do see through this
volunteer group that i mentioned our
business resource group it has again
over 50 000 members in it they are
showing up every day to do work on
behalf of their local teams their
markets
and nobody's paying them to do this it's
not their full-time job they do it off
the side of their desk in their spare
time that is passion at work right there
and often they will say this is one of
the best things i like about this job is
being able to do this and meet other
people
so it's just great that we have folks
who are really coming out all the time
we sometimes ask a lot of this community
so we have at a time probably two to
three thousand people going through
career development programs that we've
established but in order to make those
work we need volunteers to lead those
discussions i do not go out and hire an
army
of facilitators outside i actually go
out to our employee base and i ask for
people to volunteer and have discussions
with other employees here and we've had
hundreds of people devote substantial
time to do this so it's amazing i see
women coming out in all sorts of
different ways all the time
every day whether they're asked or
whether
they just come to us they're always
looking for ways to contribute
that is so important community resource
groups which is what we call them at
vayner
employee resource groups business
resource groups i agree with you it
more and more these women are stepping
up and supporting these groups and
helping to shape um you know business
and so i appreciate that you know that
same movement is happening internally
within your organization as well as ours
um i guess my last question for you is
what changes are you seeing in your
company internally and secondary to that
how are you keeping your employee
community fired up in this time
well the good news for me and the people
i work with is we are seeing more women
and more women stay in the company and
move into senior level jobs and so we
have targets against these numbers
mid-pier and also senior level in terms
of the women that we want to have at the
company so that is great and a big deal
i think in terms of the overall
investment that our company has made so
we have now a very robust formalized
diversity equity and inclusion group and
this is a global team and in addition to
focusing on women we focus on six other
communities with full-time teams and
resources and that includes the black
hispanic latino asian military and vets
disabled and lgbt plus communities
i do not know of a single other company
bank or otherwise that has made
investments in that many communities
with full-time teams i think a lot of
folks have business resource groups the
employee groups but full-time teams with
resources driving real change is really
special
and we all report up to the president of
the company we don't report into hr
and i think that's a really important
signal also because it shows that the
business is accountable for this it is a
part of their goals just like any other
business performance goal and so that
combination of the structure and the
investment i think is really great so
that's a big deal and that's the changes
we've seen in the last few years
i think for our community i'm sorry just
that
keep going sam you're that's good i'm
just happy to hear that that you're
doing all these amazing things that
chase around d e and i
it's it's real i will say that it's a
real thing um and for us we really try
to inspire our community throughout the
year and we do that i would say in two
signature ways one is around women's
history month which i think a lot of us
spend a lot of time doing which is march
we all like to bring attention to the
women in our communities but we also run
an annual leadership day for women in
the fall and i'm so happy we get to be
back in person this year we'll probably
have upwards of 2 000 people in person
and tens of thousands more watching
online but we bring people together to
talk about entrepreneurship and career
lessons and leadership and mental health
these days and we really try to keep the
community engaged around the things that
they want to here and bringing them
together i think will just be so great
once again
awesome i tell you i'm so happy that i
had the opportunity to spend this time
with you sam
i am so on board with everything that
you're doing we're doing a lot of the
same things here at vayner so i want to
be there i want to support and look
forward to being a partner with you in
all things around women and diversity
thank you vanessa great to see you
thanks to you both and that your podcast
is outstanding so hopefully everybody
can check out um women on the move um
check it out we've had i've i've really
enjoyed all of those conversations that
you've had thanks to you both for
joining us today thank you
and thanks to all of you for joining us
on our second anniversary episode of
marketing for the now
please come on back on august 24th 12 to
1 pm eastern time where we will have a
mystery episode so we hope to see you
soon
take care bye